nothing gets past the fans of westeros
even if it occasionally gets past the
hbo production team the new game of
thrones prequel series house of the
dragons sets up a different but equally
fascinating world of political
machinations revolving around the
targaryen dynasty 200 years before the
events in the main series with the
number of dragons spotted steadily
rising the series is as fantastical as
advertised but comparisons with game of
thrones can also be a double-edged sword
despite years of high quality
programming any errors the original show
made remain in the minds of hardcore
fans dedicated viewers of game of
thrones will recall that in season 8
episode 4 the last of the starks a
modern coffee cup was accidentally left
on set in a scene that takes place at
the stark home of winterfell after fans
pointed out the gaff it was quickly and
decisively disappeared unfortunately for
house of the dragon the new series seems
to be following suit though in some ways
house of the dragon is attempting to fix
the divisive plot points of the final
season of game of thrones the prequel
has also made a highly visible mistake
that is hard to ignore in a fantasy
series like house of the dragon visual
effects are of the utmost importance
mythical creatures and bloody carnage
are what makes westeros go round
but even more imperative are the small
effects needed to create the
believability of the world
and deliver this to prince damon
yourself in season one episode three
second of his name fans caught sight of
a green screen glove visible on
viserys's hand king viserys played by
actor paddy considine seems to have been
carrying a hidden affliction for the
entirety of house of the dragon thus far
while it's still not entirely clear what
is making him ill it's a small cut from
sitting the throne the glove was
obviously part of a cg effect intended
to show that the ruler is missing two
fingers ceres's supposed missing fingers
wrapped in the green screen tape were
obviously meant to be edited out on the
plus side we live in a time where this
mistake doesn't need to be permanent our
streaming services have been known to go
back and correct errors in previous
episodes to precisely this kind of issue
art director hawk richter reminisced
about the game of thrones coffee cup
debacle in an interview with variety
things can get forgotten on set it was
so blown out of proportion because it
has not happened with thrones so far
we must learn to face it with a stiff
lip
game of thrones said goodbye to the
coffee cup and it seems that house of
the dragon will follow suit it won't be
long before the image will be scrubbed
from the internet the cirrus's maggot
eaten fingers will be digitally erased
as was always intended and as executive
producer miguel sapochnick explained to
the hollywood reporter the westeros crew
maintained a sense of humor about such
mishaps he challenged viewers see if you
can see where the starbucks cups were
that we removed digitally after the fact
and if you can find one there is a prize
[Music]